Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
A quick report on what is going on with Two
Minute Papers.
We are living extremely busy times as I am
still working full time as a doctoral researcher,
and we also have a baby on the way. We are
currently a bit over 30 episodes in, and I
am having an amazing time explaining these concepts and enjoying the ride tremendously.
One of the most beautiful aspects of Two Minute
Papers is the community forming around it,
with extremely high quality comments and lots
of civil, respectful discussions. I learned
a lot from you Fellow Scholars, thanks for
that! Really awesome!
The growth numbers are looking amazing for
a YouTube channel of this size, and of course,
any help in publicity is greatly appreciated.
If you're a journalist, and you feel that
this is a worthy cause, please, write about
Two Minute Papers! If you're a not a journalist,
please try showing the series to them!
Or just show it to your friends - I am sure
that many, many more people would be interested
in this, and sharing is also a great way to
reach out to new people.
The Patreon page is also getting lots of generous
support that I would only expect from much,
bigger channels. I don't even know if I deserve
it. But thanks for hanging in there, I feel
really privileged to have supporters like
you Fellow Scholars. You're the best. And,
we have some amazing times ahead of us.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!